oh my god grand theft auto 5 came out on
pc don't you know what guitar hero is
coming back as well Justin hey what Mary
Kish y'all put up a video on gamespot
com just this morning about guitar hero
live that's what they're calling it yes
the new game is guitar hero live the the
rebirth of guitar I mean this is like
one of those worst kept secrets people
have have known about this for a while
and not just because we also played it a
couple weeks ago but even before that
like we knew this was coming they knew
this was a favorite of the rock band
stuff for people kind of had an inkling
harmonics for doing something they
announced a rock band is the new rock
bands a thing but this is really
interesting doing the two because rock
band is literally bringing back rock
band for all of the songs you have
everything all of your instruments those
are gonna work with the new rock band
whereas guitar hero are going in it in a
completely different direction there's
not only a new instrument something
completely different to buy but the way
that they're going to monetize the songs
is also very different we don't know too
much about that but it's a completely
different models that they're going
we'll get into the monetization stuff in
a moment first of all Mary the guitar
how does it feel it's like it's like
three by two or something yeah it's
totally different the old one I had five
buttons that all went down the neck
which color buttons are different it's a
totally different it's literally about
the button they've changed the strong
shake it looks pretty much the same do
you still do the do you do it this drum
is the same but a little tapper ooh is
the same but before we probably noticed
I mean they they have like a million
different guitars they had stickers they
did all this customization crap I mean
all that's different they're not doing
any that this time it's just this guitar
and it has a two by three grid of the
buttons instead of five buttons down the
neck another and it's 2 by 3 degree mess
yes to keep on some of them on some of
them are black is that okay on the when
it comes down the screen that's like
that's right so you could think of it as
like maybe makeshift cords is what maybe
what they're trying to convey a little
bit better because with the five the
only thing that you had to do with you
had to move your pinky down to hit that
fit button but now so you see this one's
all white the white is farther away and
black is closer to you and grieve so
what happens is is now your it looks
like easy right I mean when we first saw
this you you think it and you're like
walk yeah you know there's only two
colors you simplified it you made it
easier usually made it easier but it's
not it's it's difficult for your brain
to understand that if it's white black
white yeah all of a sudden you you have
to make it work this is on easy mode
yeah we haven't seen a cord here yet
right yeah it looks like one note at a
time this is this is trying to get you
into the the concept of all right so now
I'm on the buttons that are farther away
now about the buttons closer to me well
I'm over into this what the goddamn hell
is happening in here to background
according to change the backers like FMV
goddamn like just pretend look at that
guy looks like look listen they warned
when you into the rock experience by
making you act like a creeper with a
GoPro at a concert you're that you're
the guitarist and a concert it it's
interesting in some ways like this crowd
stuff that stuff you're seeing now
you're looking at the crowd that's
that's actually kind of cool and
exciting I don't know that I'd want to
see it every time there's a banana in
there if you find him there's like guy
in a banana oh really we were always we
were joking earlier like there's
probably there's gotta be at least one
person who like showed a weiner yeah
it's got to be found I mean in the
history of having extras that you pay
twenty bucks to stand there for hours
someone's going to show something gross
but there is no proof of that yet I mean
I'll tell you I edited this video so
I've seen that crowd a lot you were
looking for it and it already got old to
me oh really it is the same thing right
it's part of like an intro as well like
every level your like before you go as
long intro it's like 60 seconds but
they'll be something that they only did
for you guys because it's got a price
thing and there's just like humming it
up a bit there's no way they wouldn't
let us skip that yeah because who wants
to see that every time but it's like you
know you see these same people it is I'm
not gonna lie I mean it yeah we just
give it a butterfly is she get excited
about it but you know who knows they
were saying that they recorded something
different for every song I like I didn't
notice that we were playing here there
are different venues and that there's
also gonna be different bands like
they're gonna be themed with what you're
playing with I was also good and bad
like ghetto so it like it does it like
when you [ __ ] up yeah it's gonna like
the crowd is is not gonna be happy with
you your drummers not gonna be like oh
yeah your do really awesome he's gonna
be like you suck you piece of [ __ ] what
are you doing pick up your guitar it's
fast
meeting how different it is obviously
this is the good version everyone's
stoked to see you they're like super
happy about everything that you're doing
but when it is bad it's almost it's it's
almost you feel bad when you're playing
if you catch a glimpse of it because
your entire band looks at you like you
destroyed their career that this was
their big break it looks you're gonna
break up on stage but then the thing
about these is like you're probably just
so badly concentrating on like really I
didn't notice any of it when I was
playing and I was awful is there a
no-fail mode where they're like it's
okay buddy if you're doing alright will
you even know you're doing terribly you
don't fail out in any of that use it's
just that you're not doing that well
answer reminder that you kind of suck
one thing and I don't know anything
about this one thing that I kind of
conjecture they're going to do with this
because they were very hesitant to talk
more about what kind of bands are using
what those people are doing I bet for at
least one of those songs they're gonna
have a really like a famous band you're
gonna play with them like a green day or
like yeah somebody like that you're
gonna be all yeah see baby don't give
that stuff away for free so well that's
the interesting thing is that dlc is
going to be handled very differently in
this like so the main game because they
took so long filming each and every
performance and apparently we don't know
how many songs that's going to be in
order to Pat it out there's not going to
be a guitar hero live 2016 there's not
going to be another disc version of this
activation aren't going to analyze one
of their franchises well instead they're
going to make us a cheap chocolate is
calming flying pegs it might be worse to
have a subscription service I like I am
hesitant there there is a free version
of this like what it was called the
story or TV where you can tune in play
the game yeah you don't even need a
console for this necessarily right to
bring this in on ps4 and xbox one on one
up but the there could be a version you
can stick on your TV but we haven't
announced officially what everything's
on but they told us yes it is going to
be a mobile game that you can literally
plug into your TV and play it right off
of your phone as if it was an xbox one
you know like no different and this like
live element because there's like the
ones that they've clearly like shot all
these crowds stuff for but there's like
some sort of a service where you
basically like tuned into almost like
like old mtv music video channels where
there was like a bunch of different
channels and they're just playing songs
and you play constantly streaming
videos just music video just music
videos think of it like you would cable
so you'll have two channels that are
constantly going 24 hours a day random
songs with random songs and they're
going to program and and programming and
and then if you want to pay for my
program you mean watch so the example
they gave is like on Friday nights maybe
at a PM that's our Rock block and so you
know that by alright friday at 8pm
they're gonna be playing some rock songs
i don't maybe i don't know exactly what
songs but i'll get to listen and play
yeah here's the genre that I like Greg
genre cravings for an hour whatever yeah
everything totally Beatles all day on
one channel and then if you have the
subscription service you get access to a
whole bunch of other channels that'll
have maybe more specified towards your
liking that way you can kind of just
fine tune it in case there's something
on the regular channels that's just a
Brian core and that's when Thursday
that's what the comparison to cable gets
a little like dark to me because I mean
we've seen what's happening to both
cable you know I mean for years it's
been you get the basic package you get
the bigger package you get the deluxe
package you get the super mega package
but that increasingly people are
consumers are trying to find a way to
not do that yeah are trying to find a
way to get their content elsewhere to
not pay the subscription fees to not
like be locked in like oh if I want to
get my green day channel I have to pay
this tier so you know will they go a la
carte with it will it be that kind of
cable tier that is getting such backlash
in the network program I mean if you
want to like follow any companies model
it probably shouldn't be comcast if
we've learned anything about making
people happy you should be able to give
people exactly what they want without
making them pay for [ __ ] they don't and
we don't know what that is because they
have not brought in any of that stuff
yet I think that's like an e3 thing that
they're going to talk about yeah because
going to talk about what songs are on in
the game as well that's right yeah we
don't know what the songs in the actual
game are and that's like a huge that's a
huge chunk of it for me personally
because you know if I'm going to be
playing through with my character and
growing them and stuff I want I want to
make sure like the songs in the actual
game campaign our first thing she used
to do when I worked in retail was they
pick up the game they flip over the side
of the box read what the [ __ ] song yeah
and for a while it was like rock band
guitar hero and you'd like oh this one's
got tool great i'm going to go for that
on like that was the main sort of yeah
the decision point patina on the
positive end since it is just streaming
music you technically have access to
anything they're able to license catches
like on the flip side is kind of a cool
thing that I don't have to think about
like I might I need to buy all of these
songs I spent so much money on rock band
back in the name like an embarrassing
amount of money but then the thing of a
rock by the release is that we you know
you've got it even if you've spent all
this money on all those songs you can
play it among guitar on base on drums
you can sing them guitar hero the new
one it's just guitars right well I don't
think it's going to be just guitar
really like there's there's at least
kind of e vocals and and I think there's
going to be based right now like when we
were talking like right now we're only
talking about guitar there's not going
to be drums definitely and I and I I'd
wager like seventy-five percent there's
gonna be base there has to be x % a
while like your wage yes any percent of
the money that I make in a day dollars
like not related heaven I think I poured
out my pocket so that's way as somebody
who like I predominantly played those
games for the drums like I started off
playing guitar stuff but then like drums
was my thing so like that's kind of like
a big so you got yourself some guitar
hero world world tour drums and some
rock revolution drums even make that
move across the Atlantic funnily enough
they're all stuck in London somewhere
that's that's why i prefer rock band
still like I the guitar on guitar hero
is always better like it's a better
piece of kit and I'm kind of
disappointed that this new one is not
going to transfer over because it's
three buttons by three button like three
young pup three on the bottom that
doesn't transfer over to the the five
button neck guitar yeah and so I'm gonna
have to keep using my old guitar hero
guitar but I love playing drums and I
love singing it like I that's what I do
in rock band guitar is is fun but like
you like get drums or the fun part
getting to singing it in a fake band
it's like karaoke I'm the opposite i
liked guitar hero because i liked
focusing on one thing and being good at
it i liked finding a song that i enjoyed
you know if it was like one by Metallica
and you just play it again and again and
again until you're the best and you play
it on expert mode and then you show off
for your friends when you have a party
and then when they want you to play
something else you say oh no I'm bored
now and then you let someone else play
so you don't embarrass yourself that's
my
don't you play something good and that's
why I need to know what the campaign
list and songs are because i don't i
don't want to wait for that song to come
up on live I don't want to wait for my
cool song to come up i want that
campaign song to be good so that i know
that i can i can really show how awesome
i can be at one particular thing focus
they're gonna have an a la carte option
of some type but what is the right price
model for you like what would you pay
for that would make or what would make
that worth it is such a confusing thing
too like you can like iTunes me am I
gonna pay 99 cents per song here so I
used to be that's the way Dance Central
the way Robin was is on xbox one now
there was about playstation is 10 bucks
and then you download a bunch other
stuff waddup playstation karaoke game
the came as no playstation was def jam
rapstar I wish no that sucks the
downloadable one the this the service
one that came at just yeah year ago or
so like that type of my guess this is
the world of music has changed
fundamentally as well yeah it's weird
though how like guitar hero is now going
to be basically one instrument again and
that's rock bands niche again is like no
it's not just you playing one guitar is
the whole rock band and it's a hundred
dollars like whether you buy it on a
mobile device for guitar hero we're with
the guitar guitar hero with the guitar
and the version of the game whether you
buy it on ps4 whether you buy it on TV
or mobile yeah like you're basically
buying that that hardware is that too
much like is that the right price we
especially when you yeah rock band is
going to come out it like ostensibly a
cheaper price because it's not going to
have any hardware that's a hefty you
have seen grace I remember the first
time I bought this the first time guitar
hero ever came out in college you're
looking at what like 75 bucks with for
the game in the guitar I remember in
college was like oh like this is like
i'm not i mean raman now for the next
three weeks like this better be great
divided to rock out what was it was one
of the best purchases i made in college
I have zero regrets about buying it
which is why I'm like a little
apprehensive about saying like well
that's a lot of money it doesn't matter
if it's worth it and you don't know if
it's not worth it yet because that game
was like the mecca of every party I was
ever at for the two years that was about
six or seven years ago so enough to find
out if that's going to
the same again in 2015 at e3 is when
they're going to announce old the new
songs hopefully we'll have some more
information about the price points and
stuff like that ever would have to wait
and see and hopefully they'll show off
the VR headset version of that crowd
because why that would be cool yeah I
can be weird backstage you didn't play
just like stare at the one dude who's in
the front the whole time so looks like
am I like your cigarettes at the probe
rob was telling me in the in the demo
we're with all the developers and he was
like how like realistic are these intros
where you're like in the room backstage
with all the bullies like is there like
a big bowl of cocaine bunch of it and
then go out on set and freak out that's
how you raise your star power meter yeah
that's dlc dlc exactly don't like okay